fabrice avait deux enveloppes vous allez
avoir un échange avec les chroniqueurs à
l'issue de cet échange vous aurez de
solutions bien qu'ils ne diraient oui on
se réconcilie ou bien vous avez une
deuxième enveloppe dans laquelle il a
marqué ni comment
[Rires]
ses joies
fabrice je sais que vous avez été peiné
par ce qui s'est passé mardi et non mais
si je le dis après on ne sait pas qui a
raison qui a tort mais fabrice et la
rivalité pénétrer enfin bref quoi
comment ça arrête arrête il n'a pas du
tout été peiné il a il a eu la
possibilité encore une fois d'avoir la
lumière sur lui il a pu pendant un quart
d'heure dire qu'il s'en allait tout en
restant et il sait très bien que ici il
n'a pas d'ennemi parce qu'on est pour le
dialogue et que même si le ton monte
quand on quand on se retrouve on discute
malgré tout et puis il est très content
parce que regardent il revient donc il
n'a pas été boudé
alors en fait moi je suis mieux un
anniversaire avec un cadeau parce qu'il
ya un ami qui m'a invité à son
anniversaire donc je soutienne
anniversaire le reste moi ça me concerne
pas merci c'était pas l'anniversaire
effectivement de cyril mais je serais
pas revenu on m'a demandé de venir un
anniversaire je réponds toujours
favorablement aux invitations dans les
années
[Applaudissements]
je pensais que c'est une fête
d'anniversaire manifestement je me suis
trompé
aboudi alors fabrice est extraordinaire
que ni moi je suis une grande fan c'est
vraiment dépit des voeux tu vois c'est
la plus belle et
fière c'est vrai que j'étais un peu déçu
j'étais un peu chafouin hier parce que
je me suis dit mais à mince il vient ici
en fait ils nous aiment pas ils parlent
de nos méchamment et j'étais un peu déçu
c'est voulez vous rassurer je parle
méchamment toulouse oui vous sert à sion
est ce que diva moi je suis pas d'accord
dans le sens où c'est pas parce que une
personne elle va parler fort elle va
s'énerver qu'elle n'a pas des sentiments
derrière et moi je peux comprendre que
vous ayez d'essuyer ce mardi dernier
parce qu'en fait vous avez un grand
coeur vous êtes comme si ray vous êtes
personnes sensibles etc dans les
extrêmes dans les deux sens et en plus
vous êtes extrêmement drôle comme je
viens de le voir devant moi je vous aime
a pas mal alors du congo
non je crois qu'en fait si vous voulez
c'est intéressant parce que au fond
il ya toujours deux choses il faut être
les deux il faut des hommes de passion
et de raison il faut arrêter d'opposer
les passions à la raison on a le droit
de se dire des choses avec passion mais
raisonnablement le propos qu'est le mien
depuis le début dans cette émission
comme partout c'est à propos
raisonnables sur la crise par exemple je
m'éloigne d'un certain nombre de
personnes je ne suis pas un négateur de
la crise cheikh jamais absolument jamais
je ne suis pas un négateur de la
souffrance je les lis ici vacanciers
toujours plus tôt quand j'ai dit
qu'effectivement l'histoire de faire des
faux pas sanitaires il faut surtout pas
faire ça m'avait dit ça veut dire génial
il faut surtout pas faire milan l'a dit
dernier la souffrance des malades il
faut surtout pas faire ça mais forcément
si vous voulez on peut pas avoir une
tension aussi importante depuis un an et
demi sans qu'à un moment donné ça
rejaillit sur les uns et les autres bien
sûr nécessairement en fait mais c'est
pas grave au fond ce qu'il faut à la fin
de la fin c'est être capable
effectivement d'avoir un discours qu'il
soit raisonnée et raisonnable rien
d'autre ça c'est moi j'en ai mangé un
problème c'est que parler de passion et
de raison conseillé nous un peu fatigué
sur le plateau mais vous avez continué à
me massacrer sur les réseaux et grâce à
craybas aussi quand même à z traité
d'abruti tout ça pas été très très sacré
papa très sympathique moi j'irai moi
j'ai rien n'est sûr les oiseaux par
exemple vous pouviez j'ai mené j'ai pas
envie pouviez se passe en famille ici
c'est de rester entre nous on leur la
division c'est vrai qu'on passe pas la
télé
de l'émission après vous attaquer
personnellement sur l'airé d'abord ça ne
m'intéressait pas et vous m'avez passer
pour un abruti c'est votre droit mais ça
m'a un peu gonflé voilà et ça ça n'a pas
arrangé les choses entre nous tu es un
gars comme des pros venus j'étais encore
plus énervé et je vais magasiner non
mais je vais attendre que j'aime bien
mon propos on aurait pu être
relativement je vous aime pas mais c'est
très intéressant mais c'est très
intéressant moi je je je à la question
de pardonner ou pas allez pas le bon de
faire les bons débats mais avant ça moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est d'abord mon
repentir c'est à dire qu'effectivement
on peut moi je vais vous dire je je je
peux penser de moi ce qu'on veut c'est
pas mon problème quelque part je
m'intéresse assez peu ce que les gens
pensent de moi simplement vire il y a
moi j'ai aucune envie et j'ai aucune
intention d'offenser qui que ce soit et
si je vous ai offensé j'en suis désolé
pour des candidats mam a mais parce que
c'est la règle mais parce que c'est
effectivement un moment donné une parole
publique et elle ouvre un débat et puis
il faut être il faut arrêter si vous
voulez moi je suis une culture dans
laquelle quand on dit merde on dit merde
quoi à la populaire
si vous voulez il faut qu'on arrête
j'hésite entre deux bouquins pour cyril
y avait un qui s'appelle la foi n'est
pas un bonbon au miel existants j'aime
beaucoup cette expression la foi n'est
pas un moment nous sommes dans une
société de baby boom yen
à rhinau ce n'est pas au mieux les
l'extérieur alors il serait bon moi je
moi j'adore ce mec parce que c'est un
mec qu'on le dit quel coup lui parce
qu'il a ses idées il va aller au bout de
ses idées est ce que je retiens de lui
moi ce que j'ai bien aimé c'est que dans
une période difficile quand il ya eu le
que l'acolyte de confinement où on était
chez nous conviennent on savait pas où
on allait il venait ici il parle avec
son coeur est parlé avec ses tripes et
il disait des trucs qui était à rien ça
fait 2 nous expliquer à nous à nous
devant nos télés que je ne savais pas ça
non mais vous rigolez mais c'est vrai il
disposait pas mais c'est vrai il ya des
mecs qui arrivent et six médecins de gvt
expliqué plaint de troubles nous a
expliqué plein de trucs il ya des
médecins qui arrivait de chez paquet
l'université qui est con bégayer devant
lui wendling donc voila quand ils
restent dehors parce qu'il dit qu'il a
pas de petites passes sanitaires il est
droit dans ses bottes il ne veut pas
venir ici veut pas faire saillir l'app
store et je vous dirai ce que j'aime
chez moi or c'est la cas franchement oui
il a des couilles comme des boules de
pétanque au but c'est
logique oui j'aimerais bien gilles les
bains moi je suis un peu moins fade mais
néanmoins on a toujours débattue mais
récemment il ya quelques jours vous avez
pété les plombs c'est ça qui me dérange
alors ya eu les avocats qui sont contre
vous donc vous ériger en victime le fait
que vous présenter en politique on peut
plus discuter avec vous moi c'est ça qui
me gêne j'ai l'impression c'est un autre
division vous êtes tous cas pour jean
s'est dit mais là vous avez un mage
giraldi des parties
un hobby capoue je dois juste répondre
alors fabrice est ce que géraldine peut
revenir là où bien des halles est libre
et les chez elle fait ce qu'elle veut
mettez vous là bas maintenant c'est pas
logique parce que le public n'a pas subi
un autre test pcr pour verizon juste pas
sanitaire donc moi je suis comme le
public non mais venait lorsqu'il va vous
dire ni comment que sinon
ils voulaient alors vous voyez à la
traîne après aller la lay line qui
m'impose c'est après elle est là la
limite c'est quelle est la part de
spectacle là dedans ouais et qu'elle n'a
pas authenticité
je veux dire effectivement j'en ai fait
du spectacle incontestable mais
finalement sans doute effectivement mais
en cela je pense que personne ici n'a à
me donner de leçons sur le spectacle
hier bon soyons clairs deuxième élément
quant à gilles verdez je prends juste
propos et vous dire un truc je vous
souhaite une chose c'est de ne pouvoir
dialoguer avec personne comme avec moi
parce que s'il ya bien un mec s'il ya
bien un mec qui peut s'emporter qui est
toujours mais qui est toujours l'homme
du dialogue c'est moins vrai j'ai à dire
c'est toujours absolument toujours et en
toutes circonstances y revient toujours
tout j'ai recadré ans je me sens un peu
ému ce soit non je suis prêt mais
il m'en faudrait plus
vivante et la vérité c'est que je suis
la vérité c'est que ça fait un an et
demi la vérité c'est que ça fait quatre
mois que je vois tous les samedis et
tous les jours même la souffrance des
gens est qu'on peut pas effectivement
abandonnés sortir de là eynden et c'est
ça que j'essaye de faire passer c'est
qu'au fond les mesures qui ont été
prises elles impactent la vie des gens
les gens sont en train de devenir
complètement fous complètement
la première fois la réponse de fabrique
s'il vous plaît et c'est vrai que hier
dans le 6 à 7 on se posait la question
est ce que fabrice di vizio à utiliser
ou à celle enfin s'est servie de tpm pee
wee moi je trouve que vous avez servi
l'émission parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'à la cote des climats font insistants
et il est venu cinq minutes ce temps là
quand les gens étaient dans le trouble
c'est beau c'est se poser beaucoup de
ces normes à la location
l'acquisition des trois
épouses
c'est pas de sa faute parce que c'est
beau car qui gueule de
m'acheter une paire de baskets
oui donc donc vous êtes venus ici durant
des mois quand tout le monde se posait
des questions vous étiez ici face et
contre tous en fait on était contre vous
et pourtant vous représenter
la voix et la pensée de certains
français d'ailleurs en 10 duels d'un
français sur deux d'un france alors dans
alors sa gestion du bien maintenant
c'est sûr de garder bien
voir qu'à la télé on n'est pas tous dans
cette bienséance semaine alors il y aura
d'autres réconciliation donc j'aimerais
que fabrice prenne sa décision vous avez
deux enveloppes est ce que vous avez
décidé de le redire oui on se réconcilie
ou bien nico bukavu c'est pas la
question qui m'est posée alors c'est
quoi les enveloppes ne part pas de
réconciliation on parle de pardon pape
avait d'abord nié sa donc exactement
bien mais j'ai à pardonner à personne
moi j'en veux à personne ban est que
book alors donc non plus n'est donc
c'est quoi non plus bas c'est évidemment
je viens je la joue aussi les
chroniqueurs avaient leur propre
enveloppe et qu'on se pardonner
mutuellement ça aurait un sens mais moi
j'ai pas pardonné à qui que ce soit
évidemment enfin j'ai pas à pardonner
parce que je vous en veux absolument pas
c'est la vie alors alors est ce pas
rater des excuses
non non non non bah non donc tout le
monde pardonne afin lui pardonne oui
paris utilise aujourd'hui séjour du
groupe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]